hello steve's cat yeah i just want to
point out the cat is a huge fan and
apparently wanted to be in the interview
and now he's intimidated
i'm just over it
um so listen man i listen i i
i'm gonna i want to thank you for
bringing jonathan to life uh you did
such a phenomenal job with this i mean
that like seriously i just really great
work thank you thank you
like i actually almost got emotional
there i'm gonna hold myself yeah no
don't do that but i know how much john
means to you as well you've mentioned
before how much like your connection
with john so coming from you it's a it's
you know
thank you brother thank you
um i'm curious if you could show john
one of the scenes in the movie which
which scene would you want to show him
first that's such a cool question man
like my first instinct with that is like
he's seen every single scene of this
movie like he was directing this damn
movie through lin you know what i mean
like hey we felt him every day so and he
was giving us notes he was keeping us on
the straight and narrow and through the
edit as well the whole thing he was just
working on us um
but for me
i i think i would love to to sit with
him and there are two things that come
to mind immediately one is um boho days
the you know him and his friends
this impromptu musical theater
improvisational song that he comes up
with with his buddies in in a
in his apartment just a celebration of
of bohemia a celebration of of his life
i think i hope that he he he enjoys that
that song is back in tiktik boom in our
version and then i think why i would
love i would love to sit with him and
and show him you know you know me
attempting to channel him in that
delicate scene while trying to figure
out this very very difficult emotional
initiatory moment where he has to figure
out where we have to figure out how do
we get through such loss how do we meet
loss and how does that deepen us because
i think it's that moment where he really
accepts what's happening with his friend
what's happening with all of his friends
and with himself with his girlfriend
with his life
with loss
in its most essential form that he
he's able to get to a deeper level of
himself as a person and as a creator and
it leads him to writing boom it leads
him to writing rent and he he he has to
re-um
you know kind of
re-engage and recommit to his duty as an
artist that he feels in that very deep
way
uh one of the things about this movie
and
is that it it's constantly talking about
the finite time we have and what to do
with the time we are given and i'm just
curious how did playing jonathan and
being part of this production possibly
impact you in like your own life um and
the choices you might want to make in
the future yeah i think that's
everything dude i think that is the big
theme of the film like
how do we spend our time and and what's
the thing that's going to make us sing
that line i i want to spend my time this
way i'm going to spend my time this way
like like john gets to with realizing
that he has no choice but to finish the
hat like he has to be at the piano every
day he has to sing to the back row
even if they don't want to listen to him
he has to keep doing it um and i and i
think i've always tried to and that's
why i feel a real connection to john
because i feel like he was tapped into
some wisdom that i i try to be aware of
in my own life
um but yeah it affected me deeply and i
think again it comes back to an
awareness that our time here is very
limited and we can only really be aware
of that if we accept the idea of death
as a really a profound and important
aspect of what it is to be alive and
obviously it's a part of the journey
that john goes on himself and it's a
part of you know something that i've
been
going through in the last few years as
well i think we all have to whatever
degree going through the pandemic and of
course john was going through the his
own pandemic with the aids epidemic and
seeing
seeing his young friends from the lgbtq
plus community
getting very sick and dying at a very
very young age the the profound
awful heartbreak of that and then of
course what what other choice do you
have
but if you're going to face that death
to realize
and really um kind of integrate the
knowing that we are only here for a
short time and if we know that then then
how are we going to spend it
i i i'm curious listen man you you
you can sing and i don't know i'm just
curious like i really uh enjoyed your
work singing and when did you actually
realize
wait i can actually do this because i
know that lynn presented you know we
talked to you about doing the movie and
asked you if you could sing at what
point did you realize i can actually do
this i have a voice you know what i mean
like because i'm not sure if you ever
thought you could do it before
um i i don't know whether i considered
it you know the way i put it is
lynn
lynn made a dream of mine come true that
i didn't even know i had
you know what i'm saying like i think it
was it's been a dream of mine to be in a
musical but i didn't i i didn't own it
because i was too scared of of
potentially happening and failing so you
know sometimes it takes someone else
someone else to see to see where you can
get to clearer than clearer than
yourself right and lynn is that lynn is
this magical creature that
awakens parts of you just by being in
his orbit that make you realize or find
out aspects of yourself that you didn't
even know existed because he is so
he is so full of his own self belief his
own artistic freedom and creativity and
you know you see him freestyling and
you're like
how how are you able to reach that level
of
total free play
and brilliance like there's a there's a
self belief there that i think is
contagious so so for me it was like i
will i will trust in this genius of
musical theater even if i don't feel
confident myself i will borrow his
confidence in me and it was important
because as you know about john you watch
him singing you watch him playing piano
it's uh he's playing to madison square
guard and he's billy joel playing to
madison square garden every time whether
he's in his apartment or whether he's on
stage in the new york theater workshop
like he's he is belting like his life
depended on it which it did that's how
he experienced it so it was important
for me to get to that place
of throwing all inhibitions away and
throwing all of it at the wall and just
kind of putting it on the table and
going this is it this is me and i have
to put every single cell
towards serving jonathan's every cell